ClickBait videos!
*epic music*
It's plagued YouTube for years.
But you still click on them.
You won't stop clicking on them.
I have to clickbait just to stay relevant.
It's gone out the control and I'm here to fix it.
So I'm gonna spoil clickbait videos
So you won't have to click on them.
You're welcome.
Yes, it was painful. Yes, I wanted to kill myself.
But here we are.
Let's begin.
I shaved my head. OMG Luke shaved his head
*buzzing sound*
Is that his pubes?
I'm joking! It's just a magic effect!
It's just a magic effect! It's just a magic effect!
If The Internet Was Real 2
*nuclear attack warning*
There's no boobs in the video.
If Video Games Were Real 3.
Food Battle 2010.
Worst twist endings ever.
My new girlfriend.
?
It's not his new girlfriend
My new hot girlfrie- It's not his new girlfriend
Leerly (Literally) "?" in title
=
Not true, don't click on it.
Actually, I pull that shit fucking all the time.
*snorting cocaine*
Prankster Got Shot, Hood Prank Gone Wrong.
Almost dies.
No one gets shot.
The death of the rat (Keemstar)
Sadly the rat didn't die.
Almost died today.
It was makeup.
Pewdiepie is dead?!
Come on! x4
Goddamn, it's makeup too!
The goddamn makeup trick!
Why did I keep falling for it?!
FUCK!
It didn't even have a "?" in the title!
Teddy rape?
Where is the rape, KSI?
Why do you think I clicked on this video KSI, where is it?
Where is it KSI?
Where the fuck is it?
I came here for the title, man
Is Pewdiepie hitler?
yes
Are we dating?
*look of general despair*
*sound distorting*
*action of wtf*
*360*
Way to dodge the question!
*hits table*
*pain*
Are they dating?! I need to know!
I need answers!
*pain again*
*in the distance* I guess some questions will never be answered.
I got banged with a toothbrush...
Why do I feel like I'm Leafy right now?
What the fuck happened?
Bloopers gone wrong gone sexual.
*look of interest*
The fuck...
Where is it?
Where is it?!
[volume warning]
*intense sound clipping*
*epic music* *pewds dancing*
See what I mean?!
This is the problem!
This is an epidemic!
LOOK AT THAT DOG!
Guys, I found the cringiest kid ever.
Just kidding, here's the cringiest one.
Just kidding, this is the cringiest one!
I'm just fucking with you, THIS is the cringiest one!
aaaaaaaaaahhhhhh
No, this is the cringiest kid!
Just kidding, THIS is the cringiest kid!!
No x7
THAT'S the cringiest kid! *walks away from computer*
Guys, I'm not playing, the next one will be the cringiest one, I promise!!
The cringiest kid, the cringiest kid guys! *disappears out of camera view*
*sudden teleportation back to computer* Leafy, I just wanna know who the cringiest kid is.
Why are you busting my nuts like this?
Come on, man.
Come on.
*covers face with hand* Tell me who the cringiest kid is, I need to know.
My friend died because of me, Story Time.
Ooh
What a heartfelt story! Better click on this one!
*girl talking: "I know this seems like a strange story guys." *
*girl continuing to talk: "... But this really did happen..." *
*even more talking: "...thousand of years ago." *
*still talking: "This is the story of Easter, the real Easter." *
*Girl finishes her intro: "And the story of Jesus Christ." *
She's tal-
She's talking about Jesus!
She was talking about her friend, Jesus!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I bet Jesus wouldn't clickbait like this
What would you do?...
Extreme
They're playing Surgeon Simulator! x2
Alright, what should we name this video guys?
We gotta come up with a title.
How about Surgeon Simulator with that?
Fuck you, we're naming it "What would you do.......... *motions with hands* Extreme."
Don't believe FaZe Clan.
Because...
I can't believe this happened.
I can't believe this.
You won't believe this.
She doesn't believe me.
I can't believe these kids.
Can you believe this?
I can't believe this.
I can't believe I fell.
I can't believe it! *begins walking away*
I can't believe I found this!
I can't believe it!
*offscreen* Can you believe this?
I can't believe it!!
He can't believe it!!!
YOU WON'T BELIEVE THIS!!
Fucking hell it goes on, it goes on...
And then finally... *runs hand through hair*
Finally!
I saved the best for last.
Good old rat.
*cancer alert intro*
Leerly (Literally) if you see Pewdiepie in the title...
Don't bother, alright?
just...
Jesus Christ, man.
Why do I feel like the rat molested me?
How about you run that story for a title?
Eeeehhh
Alright. *time for seriousness*
Clickbaiting...
Almost everyone does it
If you don't do it...
You're not gonna get views.
I can spend days on a video
and it will get less views than a video that we shit out, for 10 minutes
that has a better title
YouTube is really unfair... in that regard.
And what it leads to is good content sometimes getting buried.
uuhh...
By clickable content,
and this is a problem that is bigger than YouTube
It goes into news media
And media being bias to...
I don't mean to get int- that's a whole other level.
But on YouTube...
Is it a problem and how do we solve it?
We spoil it.
One video at a time. *serious time over*
This has been absolutelly fucking awful for me.
So I hope you enjoyed this video, if you did, go ahead and leave a like.
That way I'll get more likes
And I'll have to put less clickbaity titles.
Appreciate ya.
And as always, stay awesome Bros.
*brofist*